all right John hello John uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally I
grow up in sweetport Louisana in the bay
in the
country and um it's amazing my mother
and father separated when I was 3 years
old my dad took us on the Arkansas side
so they live out in the country like one
mile away from civilization closest
thing we had to was the
graveyard me and my brother
Mike and my youngest brother my mother
gave him
away so I always had defects I want be
my mother and my
dad but they live on a little farm they
had nine
acres my grandparents they worked hard
real tight always wanted to save Penny
Pinch Penny we had to pay cotton $2 all
day and all I got was a nicker on of
there
so I went to all black school from the
beginning then one day they busted to
the white out of
town and was
integrated and I met a man named rean
Jordan he was a school teacher he was a
preacher people come every Sunday and
watching this man and I was just a kid
and he always act funny and I knew
better because his hand movement his
Swagger and he was a married man to Miss
Jordan both of B
teacher he always invit us over to his
house then one day me Den said and Mike
went to his
house back in 75
745 was a lot of money we can go across
the state line and get beer P ribon hot
beer for $3 12 pack so Faithfully this
man would take us in his CAC and when we
go through the little town has laid down
in his back seat cuz he don't want
nobody to know we would go to his house
he give us
$5 we have sex
[Music]
with but I try to explain to my
grandmother she didn't want to hear none
of
that she shush up boy he's a good
man and it go deeper than that
so he start having sex with all the kids
in the
town and people would think hly of him
especially my grandmother my
cousin he's a good man he's a teacher
he's a preacher he made somebody s where
he's having sex with all the kids Behind
the church in the
church at Mona's
house and they say he was a good man as
I got older and came to
California my uncle was in the van one
day we was out detailing cars and he
said hey
John they caught Reb Jord behind the
church with one of the student I said I
try to tell Grandma that but she didn't
want to believe
that we do strange
things play with his dick play with his
ass suckers
off then we have to hide in this car
then on the in the morning guess what he
in the church praising the
Lord and it's sad so him and Miss Jordan
they broke up because they called him
and da having sex and they had had a
son because in that little small town
people didn't want to talk about things
like that it was
taboos but the kids didn't have no money
14 15 years old here we were [__]
poor Bar M had to go out and pick peev
and sh sh peas go fishing and [__] but
them $45 was a lot of money a lot of
money but what we had to do to get it he
supposed been a decent man a common man
somebody to look up to but
unfortunately he was just a Bruiser a
molester putting [__] in our
opinions said Earl D they were laugh
and they said I was
strange we couldn't talk to Grandpa
about it he didn't want to hear none of
this [__] so what we do we [__] get
drunk they used just take her home him
and
D we be [__]
up we go up there old dirt road they
giving us
hell and they thought it was cool they
promised the world we going to come by
and give you $50
$60 all that was a lot they come back
with a bottle of boob on Friday
J and I tried to make the school one day
D picked me up because I missed the
school bus left my glasses in the house
right now I'm wearing Iron
plants I used to wear glasses thick ass
glasses sitting in front of the class
kids laugh at
me when I came to
California Monte bought me a p grass
some running from M for $50
I could see the world actually I was
still blind because I need someone to
talk
to they didn't want to hear the [__]
they said I was
strange now as I grew
up and they go back to a family reunion
some people started
talking and all begin to come out and
they just laugh about
it oh boy he just a [__] he just this
and
that they just laugh about it and that
leave a DEA not in my common sense not
in my mind but way way because when I
think of dumb [__] I be want to drink
drank every [__] day cuz I couldn't
tell
nobody cuz everybody looked up to him
the
principal I then one day Dy picked me
up and I drunk that whole
bot we still about 6 miles away from the
school and I began to walk stagging like
a
[__] I got to the school I see
Tony Johnson K St so I app myself to be
smart to go in the library crawl up on
the table and go to sleep but they saw
me they took me to the principal office
threw up I got to expelled from school I
went start breaking out the window cuz I
knew some [__] going to go down ra J Tex
me home drop me off at the goddamn Road
give me some head in car want me to play
with his [__]
nipples but he would go up the road Dr
me
off my
grandmother and a friend took me back up
to the school said no he can't come here
no more he got drunk cuz they didn't
want to hear the real realistic what I
was going
through now they didn't want to hear
that cuz they looked up to him he's a
school teacher he a preacher even his
wife Miss Junior kept it on the down low
[__]
up very [__]
up little little town maybe population
299 Emon Arkansas Google
it it's [__]
up we have to go to the stck hand store
get
clothed and my grandmother get jeans
from me and Mike [__] this long and
put patches on the knee
she didn't have much of her education my
granddad had a third grade education
work at s me but I need that extra money
I want to be cool but I was going
through
something every time you pull up to a
church or to one them J joint he was a
man of hour everybody looked up to him
he was the re the preacher the nice guy
but he wasn't [__]
[__] we talk back in C
C5 I can go a little further than
that but I couldn't talk about it they
didn't want to hear
me hush up that's a good
man
[__] finally came to the serpent he was
back in church one of the student for to
go
church then they just laugh I what I
tried to tell them that a long time
ago
they didn't want to hear but we got
older I still got a defect in my
[__]
head but it doesn't matter
today I just keep on going it is what it
is how how is this affected your adult
life it affected my adult life when I
come into people's days when I was they
said 14 15 because I wasn't it wasn't in
the open back down there like I in
California I would try to stay away from
these
people but when I went to prison I
understood we all have a problem some
people don't want to talk about
it they just live in Miser love come I
one Mis
[__] mad at the world angry at
the
world it's sad but it's
true um
just pissed me
off drugs and alcohol became a part of
your life yeah drugs in alcohol back
home we just smok weed and drank Jack
Damian Pat blue R beer he had pled for
Sunday morning he was at the church and
everybody praising him put money in in
alter having a good time s glob had a
little This Little Light of
Mine but they didn't want to hear our
story me
M we were scared cuz it was
taboo I can go beyond the limitation and
go on but I really want to talk about
it cuz I get bad I get
angry re Jord you a [__]
[__] and you watching me right now
whoever out there watching me his name
is re Jordan
was in high school in Arkansas he's a
[__] yeah you're a [__]
[Music]
[__] you've been married have
kids I was just going to ask about your
adult adult life you you've had kids
I've got one
so you were married or no
he's in
Michigan he what he live in Michigan
[Music]
Michigan where are you staying
now I stay in my tent you have a tent
yeah how long you been out here in
skro 86 since '
86 no since 72 came out here I've been
downtown since
hotel to motel here and there getting
high getting drunk trying to find
something that ain't there what's your
drug now [__] I'm smoked in a
crack occasion I smoke too crisp to stay
up alcohol too yeah I drink alcohol
every day I got scw both my to and they
give me trod dolls the [__] don't even
work when I'm walking down the
street these screws and both my toes I
be hurting like a
[__] I just take hit the cocaine
or snort keep from hurting
man keep [__] hurting helps with the
pain yes he have the pain when I take my
shoes
off if I touch something cold sh
pain and I have a walker I need two
Walkers taken from me [__] about
about 610 taken from
me it's dark dark world
man and we got a lot of people down here
have been through the same thing but
they don't want to talk about
that it was hard for me to talk about it
but it's true and brother Jordan you a
[__]
[__] if that had never happened to
you as a young man do you think your
life would have looked very different
very much so because
people they don't want to listen to me
they don't want to listen to Mike you
know they they don't they don't want to
listen to the kid when the kid got to
say something cuz that duck is always
right but I you want to remember one
thing
listen understand
comprehend don't just act like it's okay
cuz it's not okay not at all we supposed
to be better than that how did it make
you feel as a young man that no one
would listen to
you well I I I I got angry I would go
out in the corn field and cuss I learned
how to cuss I cuz my my grandparents
they didn't listen and they they didn't
want to hear that
[__] they didn't want to hear that so me
and mighte go out to the corn fi and
cuss we want to be with our
mom but we stay with our grandparents
out there in the
woods fleeing the cow slopping the hall
rying the goddamn M horse fire [__]
up going G
gun yeah that was fun but they would
listening at us they was always right
[__] then the
day everything come to a
conclusion why they got the internet
they got all the new
technology so he he got exposed he got
caught yes he got caught yes he got
caught I just said ear if I can refresh
my memory behind the church with another
boy and all he did was
laugh he did prison time I don't know if
he did prison time because I was out
here and my uncle told me then he called
my grandparents which she dead now and
somebody tell what happened to re John
and I'm the phone in the van oh her
sh like wow for
real lack of communication lack of
understanding and that's
sad what's your what's your greatest
fear now at this point in your life how
old are you I'm 62 I just turned 62 last
month 62 what's your greatest fear now
my greatest fear is when I well it's not
that I'm a read but I'm scared what I
might
do to someone to try to harm
me and I try to stay away keep my
distance and it hurt and I can see
through the
[__] somebody get too close to me I
ain't happy I don't even want to
talk hell
no
I still have my little
dram my toes hurt like a [__]
like now had bun cut Fe like
this him like that but I wish I would
never got him I'm hurting like a
[__] when I
walk but I just keep on
going keep on going John what would you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life the most important
lesson I learned is to
when you say something mean say what you
mean and mean what you
say because I'm not perfect but I know I
make a difference and how I make a
difference it just tell like it is and
when I said tell it like it is where you
believe me or not that's on
you getting [__] in ass sucking b$
or5 going to get high to the pool
hall I ain't got no goddamn way home you
know how the story
go all be somebody Lu in the
dark it's a goddamn
sh taking advantage of the
we [__]
you all right John thank you so much for
sharing your story you're quite
welcome